-Our first guest tonight
is a Tony Award-winning
and Oscar-nominated actor
you know from films such as
"Tick, Tick...Boom!,"
"The Eyes of Tammy Faye,"
and from his role in "Angels
in America" on Broadway.
He stars in FX's "Under
the Banner of Heaven."
The first two episodes premiere
tonight exclusively on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Allen has already admitted
that he's lost his faith and --
-Well, if a lack of LDS faith
gets a man convicted,
a whole lot of people
heading to Draper prison,
me included --
-I'm not saying that.
I'm saying, leaving the church,
that would have created
a lot of grief in his family.
They would have put a lot
of pressure on him to return,
to save themselves the
humiliation of a wayward son.
And the Laffertys, they're kind
of like Utah Kennedys.
-Good thing I voted for Nixon.
-Please welcome back to the
show Andrew Garfield, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Hey!
-Lovely to have you here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nice to have you here with me.
Thanks for coming.
-That's very nice of you.
That's a real power move,
you saying,
"It's nice to have you here."
-Nice to have you guys here
on my "Late Night" show.
-Thank you.
Thank you for joining us
and letting yourself be joined.
-Yes.
-Congratulations on this show.
This is a very famous book
by Jon Krakauer.
-Yeah.
-Came out, I guess,
over a decade ago, probably.
-Yeah.
-Did you read it
when it came out?
-I did.
I kind of gobbled it up.
It's an incredible book called
"Under the Banner of Heaven,"
as Seth said, by Jon Krakauer.
And it's kind of a dissection
of the Mormon faith
and the history of Mormonism
and connecting it to a modern
kind of awful murder event
that happened
in the '80s in Utah.
This amazing woman,
Brenda Wright Lafferty,
who had the courage,
as a woman in the Mormon faith,
to question the kind
of patriarchal structure.
And hopefully, our series is an
honoring of her and her memory
and the memory of her daughter.
And within it, I play
a fictionalized character,
a detective, Jeb Pyre,
who's also a Mormon
going through
his own crisis of faith
as he is pursuing
the truth of this case,
so he's kind of stuck between,
you know, the truth and his,
you know, family life,
his community.
He could potentially
lose his wife and his kids
if he starts to really unpick
the foundations of his faith.
It's kind of
an interesting dilemma.
-I knew you did
a lot of research.
You talked to a lot of people
in the Mormon faith.
Were not willing to go
full method
for the Mormonism,
though, correct?
As far as, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-It would require --
-Yeah.
-More than I'm willing
to offer, yeah.
-'Cause, like, you wouldn't
be able to, like --
I mean, you'd have to, like --
no coffee, right?
-No coffee.
I think I'd have to be married
to get to the celestial kingdom,
which I am not, you know --
-But the coffee.
-I know, the coffee.
Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
No sugar.
It's a really -- You know,
their body is their temple.
Listen, there are so many things
about the Mormon faith
that I found really --
like, the sense of community
and there's a real kind of
kindness with modern Mormons.
But, yeah, the coffee thing,
you know, no way.
-Yeah.
-There's no way.
-You kind of, like,
stop listening.
They're like,
"it's community faith."
Like, "I'm sorry, I'm hung up
on coffee right now.
It's gonna be a hard time
for me to move on."
So, last time you were here,
it's a while back now,
you were talking
about "Silence."
You played a Jesuit priest
in that.
"Eyes of Tammy Faye,"
televangelist.
And now this.
Is it a coincidence, or is it
interesting to jump into these?
'Cause these movies
aren't just about faith,
but obviously there's a huge --
or TV shows, I should say.
It is an element to all three.
-Definitely.
But also, I would even say,
"Angels in America,"
which you mentioned, is maybe
the most spiritual kind of text
of all of the things
you've talked about.
And like, something like
"Tick, Tick...Boom!,"
like, Jonathan Larson
was a kind of monk
devotee of musical theater.
So I think there's
a spiritual element
to everything
that I feel drawn to.
And I think it's really
about people
reckoning with life and death
and the deepest questions.
And I think, weirdly enough,
maybe Jim Bakker is
the least spiritual person
I've ever played.
There's something kind
of interesting about that.
-Yeah, because
he's just a con man.
-Well, I don't know about that.
I have to defend him
a little bit,
but he was definitely
kind of seduced
by the things that
we're all seduced by,
which is kind of
a sense of our own
not-enough-ness,
which makes ourselves, you know,
feel like we need
to fulfill ourselves
through money
and power and status
and things that you wouldn't
know anything about.
-No, 'cause, for me,
it's just coffee.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
I'm a fan of true crime.
I also do love when,
in a project like this,
it is paired
with something else, right?
It's not just about a mystery,
like you mentioned.
Like, it is a crisis of faith,
both of the victim
and, you know, the detective
who's investigating the case.
Are you a true-crime
fan yourself?
-I do enjoy --
I think, recently, I actually
said this in an interview.
I don't know why
I'm repeating it again.
Why am I doing this to myself?
But someone said that, "We heard
you love true crime, Andrew,
and you're an easy
sell on this."
I was like, "Yeah, are you
saying I'm easy, like
I'm a slut for true crime?
Like, I guess I am a slut."
I'm doubling down.
-You're doubling down, yeah.
-I'm a slut for true crime.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For true crime.
Just for true crime.
-You know, the problem is,
with digital technology today,
they can just edit
that last part off.
[ Laughter ]
-They can edit my outfit
as well.
-There's a lot of --
You're a floating head saying,
"I'm a slut,"
and, like, a hard cutout.
-Oh, now someone is
definitely gonna do that.
-Yeah, no, I really have laid
out a pretty
easy-to-follow road map there.
[ Laughter ]
So, you mentioned
"Angels in America."
I saw you in
"Death of a Salesman."
I think I talked about this
last time you were there.
The night I saw it,
I then went to a bar,
and you were there afterwards.
Maybe I haven't.
And you were talking
to the woman
who played your mother,
who was wonderful.
-Linda Emond, yeah.
The great Linda Emond.
-And it was too late.
I realized it too late.
But it was obviously
such an intense show to perform.
And you guys were sort of deep
in conversation.
I just walked over,
I was like, "Hey! Great job!"
And you were both like, "Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
I realized, like,
"Oh, it definitely takes them
a little bit longer to get out
of performing the show
than it did for me to,
like, watch, seeing the show."
And that was Mike Nichols.
-Directing it, yeah.
-And, you know,
I just read his biography,
which I loved.
And I was wondering if you could
tell me,
because I only met him once,
obviously, you know,
here was this guy
with an incredible career,
and you would assume,
with the wide shot,
he was just,
like, living on the high life.
And yet it was really a book
about how this great artist
constantly had doubt,
even though it seemed
like one of his skills
was taking doubt away from the
performers that he worked with.
-That's so interesting.
Yeah, I think that's true.
I think it's so reassuring when
an icon and a legend exposes
that they are
just as insecure as you are.
I remember, one of the first --
I have a story
that just came to me now,
perfect for a late-night show.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine that.
So, I enter the first week
of rehearsal,
and I am riddled
with insecurity,
as one always is when one
is putting on a play
or making a film or doing
anything human, for that matter.
Just walking down the street,
riddled with insecurity.
[ Laughter ]
And I remember
coming up to Mike,
and him just kind of looking
at me with this kind of benign,
just kind of appreciation of me,
and I'm just full of doubt.
And he says, "You know,
I'm not worried about you
because you really don't think
highly of yourself at all."
[ Laughter ]
And it was like a kind of
blessing of the wound
of being a person,
of being someone who just
struggles, like we all struggle.
And to hear him say,
"You're just like me,"
and it was about a woundedness
that I have,
I was like,
"Oh, my God, you are --
You should be
everyone's grandfather,
whether they're in the theater
or in film or otherwise."
And that was another thing
about him,
is that he became
a kind of mentor
to everybody
that he would meet.
And I think, like Sondheim
became, you know.
And it's just a beautiful thing.
And the way he directed was,
he would tell stories.
We would finish a scene
at the table,
and he would tell some kind of
seemingly inconsequential story
about a party
where he met Elia Kazan
and asked him about,
you know, naming names.
And then he'd be like,
"Okay, try it again."
And then suddenly you're
doing the scene properly
because of some aspect
of the story that has,
like,
affected your unconscious.
And suddenly you're in the scene
in a way that -- I don't know.
He was a magician and elegant
and yet deeply, deeply insecure.
-Yeah, I met him.
Like I said, I met him once.
And yet it was a very short
interaction,
where I felt like he,
like, managed to transfer
a little bit of light.
And I thought, "Wow, you
probably knew, for the whole,
like, sort of second
half of your life,
you knew that people wanted
something from you."
And he seemed very good
at giving it.
-I think he was one of
those rare people
that didn't want to be the
richest man in the graveyard,
but actually knew that we don't
get to take anything with us.
You know, we are meant
to leave it all here.
And I know Sondheim
was like that.
And I know that Mike
And Rupert Murdoch doesn't seem
to be like that.
-Less, yeah.
-Yeah, slightly less.
-If you had to order the three,
I think, like,
maybe Mike and Sondheim
are, like, one and then, like --
-Coming in hot at number three.
-Yeah, number three.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, last thing before you go,
you know, there was a bit
of a controversy here
on the show
when your "Spider-Man"
costar Tom Holland
was here and he said something.
-What happened?
-Well, he was talking about,
you know, there were three
Spider-Men in that last movie.
You were one of them, and he was
one of them, and one suit.
He mentioned that one --
Let's just take
a look real quick.
-I'll give you a spoiler,
and I'm not gonna tell you who,
but one of us
has a fake ass in their suit.
-Really?! Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-You can figure out that
for yourselves.
-Well.
[ Laughter ]
-He's just stirring the pot,
old Tom.
He can't help himself.
You know, there's an expression
that we have in entertainment,
which is,
we want to put bums on seats.
You know, we want to get
the audience sat
and paying their tickets,
and Tom is pretty great
at creating subgenres of games
for you all,
while you're in
the cinema going,
"Well, that butt
doesn't look real.
Toby's looks like
it might be real.
Could Andrew have that much ass?
Maybe, potentially."
-So it seems like we're not
gonna get an answer for you.
-All I know is, is that
I am totally unmodified,
and that's all I can --
I can share.
And I think Tom is
very good at marketing.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know what?
I'm not gonna ask
for more than that.
You have given us
a great gift as well.
You guys,
that's Andrew Garfield.
FX's "Under the Banner
of Heaven"
premieres tonight on Hulu
with new episodes available
on Thursdays.
We'll be right back.